we turn now to a warning about american
taxpayer money possibly getting into the
hands of terrorists as chaotic and
deadly as the u.s withdrawal from
afghanistan was last year it seemed the
country had put afghanistan and the
trillion dollars we spent there behind
us
but tonight the inspector general who
oversees money sent to afghanistan says
not so fast rhonda
that's right brian the people of
afghanistan are suffering terribly under
their new rulers the taliban starvation
the collapse of medical services women's
rights trampled in an economy and free
fall
the u.s has offered humanitarian aid but
this is a country with a legacy of
corruption and a government tied to
terrorists brian
we're joined now by john sapko the
special inspector general for
afghanistan reconstruction who for the
last decade have been watching what the
us has spent tens of billions of dollars
and what's happened to that money mr
sapko we're out of afghanistan now but
we're still sending hundreds of millions
of dollars to afghanistan
uh you're absolutely correct and it's a
pleasure to be here brian uh
we
meaning the u.s government because of
the humanitarian crisis or
have sent over 380 million dollars
and so has the u.n is saying they need
up to eight billion dollars
because of the humanitarian crisis
is that money going to end up in the
hands of the taliban a terrorist group
well that's the big concern as you said
in your recent speech we've seen this
movie before yeah yes we have and uh
the concern is that
uh we're going to spend too much money
and too fast and too small a country
with too low oversight and unless we're
very careful the money will be diverted
and potentially lost and go to
terrorists
as you look back on your decades running
the special inspector general's office
for afghanistan how much money do you
think was wasted that went there of the
tens of billions
well
you know that's a tough question we
we've been asked by congress uh on a
number of occasions to document
total amount lost
we
gave a very conservative estimate of
about 30 percent uh it could be higher
but about you know three
three dollars out of every 10 was lost
to waste fraud or abuse
so how do you prevent that from
happening now with the money we're
sending supposedly to help the
humanitarian crisis well the first thing
is learn from the prior mistakes
make certain you
have an acceptable you agree beforehand
on an acceptable amount of risk you're
willing to take and if it the risk
exceeds that stop spending it
the
monitor the money
see how the money is being spent i mean
these sound like really simple
proposals but they weren't carried out
in the past what was your reaction as
you watched the rapid chaotic withdrawal
of u.s forces and personnel from
afghanistan
well i think i like anybody who watched
were
saddened by it and concerned
myself
we had staff in afghanistan at that time
uh
u.s employees because we had the largest
law enforcement u.s law enforcement and
u.s audit presence in afghanistan at
that time so we were concerned about
getting those people out which we
fortunately did
as an inspector general you're
independent non-political what do you
say about the performance of the biden
administration in terms of afghanistan
well
i'll just say there there are plenty of
uh
mistakes that were made by all
administrations and you read our reports
going back 10 years
this is not a partisan issue this is an
issue of a good government and uh
and
i i think uh
i i i'm not going to say one
administration was worse than the other
we've had multiple administrations of
multiple parties and they're all
problems that we've identified
finally let me ask you this given what's
happened in afghanistan did we
accomplish anything
yeah we did accomplish quite a bit uh
unfortunately with the loss uh to the
taliban a lot of those gains
uh
are in peril and uh i think the most
obvious one that
your your viewers would recognize is
that when you know we tried to bring
some semblance of uh uh
of uh human rights protection for women
and girls uh and uh
that is
is in peril um
and uh
because the taliban although they have
said they respect women's rights uh we
really haven't seen much of that so uh
i think the gains we have made in health
care in education uh
those are all been uh
well
i would say totally destroyed but
they're likely to totally be lost
john sapko the special inspector general
for afghanistan reconstruction thank you
so much for being with us here tonight
it's a pleasure to be here thank you
up next this week's winners and losers
in the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
you